[Music]
I remember my first introduction to the
martial arts
I was only about four or 5 years old as
I watched in amazement as a little
Oriental man performed seemingly
impossible Feats of skill and power a
seed was planted that day a seed which
grew silently within my heart for the
next 10 years of my young life I never
forgot the exhibition that I had seen
that day and I dreamed of the
possibility of doing those things which
I had watched that little old Asian man
demonstrate with such ease but little
did I realize the darkness into which
this path I was now following would lead
nor the lives that my decision that day
would influence and forever
change today the martial arts are looked
upon as Sport AS self-defense health and
fitness and often as a form of artistic
expression but is this the way it has
always been who are these men and women
who dedicate their lives to these arts
and amaze onlookers with their
incredible Feats of almost superhuman
strength and speed how are these
abilities attained and from whence comes
the philosophies and spiritual teachings
which permeate these
practices why do we see such a growing
influence of Eastern philosophy and
mystical practices within the Christian
church over the last 10 years are these
practices focused merely on athletic
ability or are they being used to
prepare mankind for the coming of a war
World teacher and a thousand years of
Peace are these Eastern mystical Arts
based merely on human talent and ability
or is there something much darker and
more elusive working behind the
scenes the first time that uh that I was
exposed to martial arts I don't I don't
remember where I was but I remember I
saw something on television and it was a
it was a picture of this little Chinese
man and he was demonstr ating martial
arts ability and he took an
egg and set it on the ground and stepped
up onto the egg and stood there and it
was only for you know 20 seconds but he
stood on top of that egg and then he
stepped off and I was a little child
that's always stayed in my mind you know
when I saw that cuz I thought wow you
know that's almost like a miracle you
know that he could do that when I was 12
years old uh my parents went through a
separ separation and a divorce and it
devastated My Life um I became very
rebellious I was angry you know I know
that neither one of my parents ever
intended to hurt me but I felt I felt
abandoned I felt rejected I felt like I
wasn't worth fighting for
and during that time I began really
searching for some purpose to life for
some reason um to be a man I mean what
is the reason for being
here and I remember talking to my mother
one day about possibly looking for a
martial arts school because that memory
that of seeing that picture always
stayed in my in my mind and we found a
school downtown in the the city where I
lived and we went we went down there one
evening after she got off
work and I remember to this day that
walk we were walking down the street it
was a downtown a rough part of the town
and the dusk was coming in the only
lights uh were the street lights and
they were just beginning to
glow and while we're walking down there
I mean you can see like the pool hall
they're turning the lights on there the
the night life was starting to awaken
there's all these old brick buildings
and warehouses uh and we're walking down
the sidewalk and all the shops were
closed all the little mom and pop stores
and we finally came to this building
this old brick building it was probably
three stories maybe four stories tall
and I remember when my mom and I were
walking up we're looking for this door
for a name of a school and we were
expecting it to be you know like it is
today you know this really elaborate
nice modern and we found this little
doorway I mean it was it wasn't even a
full door a tiny little wooden door and
it had the name of the dojo on the door
so we opened the door up
and as soon as we opened the door up we
could look up and we could see a light
at the top of the narrow staircase and
my mom and I started walking up that
staircase and as we're walking up we
could hear the shouts uh the Kia uh the
students you know yelling we could hear
you know the instructor you know
commanding the students what to do and I
mean I remember feeling my heart begin
to Quicken and I was like I'm finally
here you know something I've dreamed
about you know
forever and we got to the top of the
steps and we stepped into the
studio and here's this man um in a white
uniform with this old black belt I mean
it was you know just faded with age and
he's giving these orders to these
students and there was the utmost
feeling of respect I mean all these
students are doing exactly what he says
exactly when he says it and they're
doing these these forms these cotas you
know punching and blocking and um the
kicks and the
yells and I remember trying to take in
the whole scene um there's calligraphy
you know Japanese calligraphy and Noonan
calligraphy on the walls and there's
pictures of Old Masters and people that
have died you know the founders of the
art and we stayed there for probably 35
40 minutes you know watching when the
instructor got a break he came back over
to us and you know started talking with
my mother and I I had to have my mom's
approval you know to do
this and I remember the instructor you
know talking about the classes and the
schedule and I was getting so excited
and then we got down to the end of how
much does it cost and this was back
probably
83 um ' 82 somewhere in there
and he tells us the price and you know I
saw my mom's eyes and I knew it was too
much you know cuz we were very limited
on her income with my mom and dad being
separated and uh you know we thanked him
told him we would think about it and we
walked out of uh the dojo we walked back
down those steps I remember as we were
walking down those steps and I stepped
out onto the
street it was like the wind had been
taken out of my sails I thought you know
here this dream was and I thought this
was it and now I knew there was no way
that we could do it because the price
was just too
much so my mom and I are walking down
the street and I could sense that my
mother felt uncomfortable not just about
the price but more importantly she felt
uncomfortable about something in the
dojo and even though I was so excited
about you know participating and
becoming part of this I had sensed the
same thing it was I was raised as a
Christian you know we went to church
every
Sabbath and yet there was something
about what we had wish witnessed about
the the power and about the the violence
about the the actions of the art that
just didn't match and I couldn't put my
finger on it and it didn't make me feel
good so I just dismissed
it and I knew my mom couldn't dismiss it
so we went home that night and I didn't
ask her what was on her mind and she
didn't tell me but I knew
a friend of mine their older brother was
uh there at lunch he was a a junior or a
senior he a couple years ahead of me I
was in high school and he started
telling about this martial arts school
that he had found a kung fu school in
the area and he had been training there
for you know probably a year or two and
he was talking about it and I just I
asked him I said well how much does it
cost and he said he said you wouldn't
believe it he said it's a dollar a night
and I was like you're serious he said
yeah and I said what kind of school is
it cuz I was thinking about my mom's
apprehensions and uh he told me he said
the guy's a Christian he said they have
a Bible verse every night he said we
train we fight um it's a Christian
school and it's a dollar every time you
come there's no
contract and I was I was I was so
excited it was like all of a sudden my
my hopes and my dreams
revive I went home and told my mom about
it and she was excited
so the following week my best friend and
I we decided to go visit this school so
we get to the school that evening and I
remember walking in the door and it was
it was very different from the the okan
school The Karate Dojo we'd went to when
we walked in this was a very very old
building single floor
um there were all these pictures when I
walked in I remember walking past the
wall all these pictures of the higher
level students in the school from the
past you know 25 years there was
pictures of the men that had made black
belt there had only been three up to
that point in uh in over 25 years uh
pictures of the instructor pictures of
the military background pictures of U
just all these intriguing mystical you
know ideas thoughts of the martial arts
so we got
there and I began
training and this school was very unique
they they BAS rank on your ability and
there were only four ranks you had white
green brown and black and you could get
a stripe in between which meant you just
a little bit ahead of the other guys but
in the only way to achieve rank was
fighting and we fought full contact you
know with boxing gloves 14 12 14 16 ounz
boxing gloves and we also fought what's
called empty hand or open hand the thing
that really intrigued me the most about
this school was is because it was a kung
fu school the fighting when it was done
open hand was based on what's called
animal Styles so if someone was a tiger
stylist if they were good when you watch
them Spar or watch them fight you would
see them mimicking you know the Motions
of a tiger with their hand positions
with their blocking with their
stances um if someone was a snake style
you would see the heads of the snakes or
the heads of the Cobra as they were
fighting you would see the techniques um
and then the instructor his primary
style although we taught all of them his
primary style was praying mantis so when
they would fight you would see the hand
positions like the praying Manis and the
Manis was a close end style it it drew
its opponent in and crushed them on the
inside
and I was so overwhelmed you know after
that first night of seeing all these
things and and the guys you know kicking
and I looked and I thought you know
that's power that's not just power but
control it was like my life felt so out
of control I felt like I didn't have any
control over anything that was happening
to me and this is what I wanted I
thought that's what I want I want to be
able to control my circumstances I want
to be confident I want to to believe in
myself I want to know that whatever I
set my mind to do I can do when we're
there in class you could tell the the
order the hierarchy if you will you know
the white belts were the beginners and
they listen to the green belts and the
green belts were terrified of the brown
belts and the brown belts didn't want
anything to do with the black belts and
there was this this pecking order um of
authority the thing that intrigued me or
caught my my attention to want to make
green belt to desire that green belt was
one night a week at 10:00 after all the
other students had left the school those
that had made Green Belt were allowed to
come in to the school and they would
shut the door on the training room and
they got private instruction from the
the
the teacher and no one was allowed to to
see or to talk about what was you know
taught in there so it was like
immediately it's like what's behind the
curtain I mean I want that and you saw
the green belts their ability you saw
what they could
do so you wanted to have that ability
and and you realize the only way that
they had that ability was because of
that special training they were getting
you know behind closed
doors well after I made Green Belt you
know I got to go into that first class
and I remember um there there was sort
of a a basic initiation when you stepped
into the class into that high rank class
you lay down on the on your back on the
floor they'd raise your shirt up and
every single one of them would get two
slaps with an open Palm on your belly as
hard as they felt you were able to to
handle and nobody was uh nobody was
going to get seriously injured but I can
remember I had marks on my stomach for
you know four or 5 days afterward I mean
it bring blood to the surface but then
you felt like you're part of something
like you you had earned
it so I stayed there and I trained for
approximately two years um we had Bible
verse each night you know there were
people that gave their hearts to the
Lord made professions of
Faith but then I got to where I was
graduating high school and my dad
offered to put me through college he
said Eric if you'll move down here with
me you know outside Chattanooga he said
I'll pay for your college so I moved I
hated to leave that school because it
you know it meant so much to me but that
was the only school I'd ever you know
trained in I didn't know there was
anything else out there and we were told
that you know we're number one this is
the best school there's no other styles
that do it like we do and I thought well
this will give me a chance to find out
if that's true so when I when I moved uh
down to Cleveland Tennessee right
outside College Dale um I started
looking for a school went through the
phone book and you can open the phone
book up and there's all these
advertisements you know and the bigger
the town is the more schools there are
the more dojos and Studios and you know
some of them would would list at the top
you know the instructor this is how many
you know degrees of a black belt he is
he's a fifth Dawn he's a sixth Dawn you
know and you look at those you go wow
this guy's got a lot of experience um
and then they would list the the
different styles or Arts that they would
teach and almost all of them said you
know self-defense self-confidence
self-esteem so it really
they lured you in they knew what people
were
lacking I look back now you know after
my conversion and I realized that all of
those things that they offer can truly
only be found in Jesus Christ it can
only be found in absolute faith in the
word of
God but I wasn't there at that point um
I'd walked away from church walked away
from God when I was 14 years old um I
just got I got tired I said you know
there's no power in this I go to church
every week I'm hearing the same verses
over and over again um but it didn't
change my life you know I went to church
and I heard sermons but it didn't help
me deal with the problems I was having
with you know girls and with lust or
didn't help me with the problems with
you know the guys at school that were
threatening me or you know the bullies
so in my mind I thought you know Church
must be a good idea but it's not helping
me in my practical everyday life
I can do something
else so in a very subtle way the enemy
was moving me from one religion into
another I began to look for those
answers in martial arts that I wasn't
finding in the church and
unfortunately the answers were there I
mean I felt like I was getting control
um I wasn't afraid of the bullies
anymore um I became very um adamant my
mouth sometimes s would get ahead of
what my body was able to do but there
was a pride that was growing within me
about the abilities that I was learning
in the martial
[Music]
arts I went to a couple of schools while
I was there in Cleveland um the first
one when I was at College was an isan R
school I trained with them for two and a
half years while I was there in in
college so I heard about a place um a
class that was held at the YMCA my dad
told me he said Eric try the YMCA I
thought dad I mean there's not going to
be anything at the YMCA I mean that's
like kids stuff so I went to the YMCA
one night and I walked into a class
that's known as Burmese Bondo or Bondo
boxing and it's from Burma they had a
great influx of the influence from the
Chinese above and from the okon and the
Japanese so it was like there was a mesh
of these uh Oriental ideas when it came
to combative Arts um they believe very
heavily in in full contact they did
boxing they did empty hand and they did
animal Styles although they were
different animals than what I was used
to with the Kung Fu it was it was
similar it was very easy to adapt I
trained with them for uh for 5 years
before I made black belt in that style
and during that time we went to a
national kickboxing tournament it's
probably the biggest event that I'd ever
been to personally there were hundreds
of people there and I remember I was a
nervous wreck you know cuz I'd never
fought in front of that many people and
they've got spotlights on you and it's
just you know it was really
nerve-wracking but then when you get out
there and I remember stepping into the
ring and I was looking around at all
these people that were around me and
they've got a card girl walking around
you know in a bathing suit holding up a
number and and I'm thinking is this real
and you know there was butterflies in my
stomach you know how am I going to do
you know all these people are watching
and then the other guy my opponent
climbed in the ring on the other side
and when I looked at him and our eyes
met everything else was gone it was like
I didn't see anybody anymore I didn't
hear anything the crowd was gone all
that mattered was the battle that was in
front of me
and when I look back at that at that
fight it really changed me and when I
came back I mean there was a a newspaper
right up about uh me and the other team
members from our from our martial arts
studio um that had made you know the
grade that had had achieved and and
pride was built a little bit
more after 5 years of hard training in
the burmes style of Bondo I achieved
black belt and my instructors encouraged
me to begin teaching the art to others
but there was something missing
something of which I had not attained
and shortly thereafter I decided to
return to my first school for I wanted
to test my skills now in the place where
I had begun but little did I realize the
spirit that was influencing my decision
nor the darkness into which this path I
was on now led during this time I saw
the Fourth Man in the history of our
school the chief black belt it was the
first ceremony of this type I had ever
before witnessed an event which inspired
me with awe so when I came back to the
art you know I started back where I was
as a green belt and within six months
I'd made Advan green within another year
and a half I'd made brown belt
and the instructor knew that that I
wanted to be able to teach I wanted a
black belt in this style during that
time I got to see that advanced brown
belt make black belt and it was the
first ceremony that I'd ever been to
like
that candles and it was very intense and
I remember the instructor looking at me
as this other man was being promoted and
I knew that's going to be me one day I'm
going to make black Bel here and 1999 I
was the fifth person to make black belt
in that school fifth person in almost 30
years and it took me 14 years of
training to do that you know while I was
training in these Arts um most of that
intense uh internal training came in the
high rank class behind closed doors when
we trained in that class there was an
idea that was introduced to us and that
was the idea of something called Chi now
that term is is thrown around even on
sitcoms today it's everywhere it's in
health magazines it's in dentist offices
but back in the80s and the '90s this was
not something that was thrown around to
just
everybody and the way that it was
described To Us by our instructor was
isqi is something that God put within
man it's internal strength it's
something that you have to learn to pull
from within you and to focus it into
your techniques whether that be kick a
bag or punching somebody or being able
to do 200 push-ups without stopping you
had to take the strength from within and
draw it up and put it into whatever you
were going to do and that I I knew this
is what we need this is the key to why
those brown belts and those Advanced
brown belts and black belts can do the
things that they do and you know we see
nowadays you know in films uh Hollywood
films as as well as documentaries you
see men breaking huge you know 500 pound
blocks of ice or breaking solid Timber
you know boards not these little Pine
boards with pencils you know inserted
between them but real things so we asked
about you know how do we learn this and
I can remember the instructor telling us
you know as advanced Green Belt he said
this type of training is reserved for
black belt he said I can show you pieces
of it how to get you ready for that but
you won't really learn about how to tap
into the chi until after black
well one of the things that we did that
helped us to bring this this this power
up from within us was it was called pain
class and I remember the first night
that we did this the instructor had been
warming us up to this idea as students
for a couple of weeks well we got there
and I would face off with my partner
you'd pick somebody that was equal rank
as you we started off with smacking each
other in the face and he would smack me
and I would smack him and you'd start
off with something like that and it
increased each smack was harder so he'd
smack me a little harder and I'd smack
him a little harder and you're looking
at each other staring each other right
in the eyes and it was harder and harder
and this went on for 5 minutes until you
keep getting harder and you could see
the green belts that were nervous they
were taking it easy on one another and
then you'd see the brown belts where
they were I mean just hitting each other
hard with an open palm and they were
feeding off of one another's aggression
almost like
sharks and so we would do the face and
then we would do the arms and we would
do the legs and then we would bring out
a board and usually it was a 1 in uh
solid um oak board or hickory board and
you would stand there and tense up your
body and allow them to strike you in the
stomach and you had to channel your
breathing so when you're being hit you
breathe out and and very intense and our
instructor told us that this was the
first step in learning how to how to tap
into that that internal strength that
was supposedly inside of us something
that happened that night that that
really intrigued me and I look back now
and I understand it more than I did
then he did not allow us to fight after
we did that class and normally we always
fought after high rank class there was
no fighting allowed and years later I
asked him about that and he said because
you're too keyed up after going through
that you'd hurt each other he said you
wouldn't hold
back so that that stuck in my mind in
the martial arts there is a division
between Styles some styles are called
internal some styles are called external
Styles the external styles are styles
that focus on really developing the
physical body while the internal Styles
Focus almost intensely on breathing and
being able to tap into the chi into this
internal
strength within those styles the
Japanese have a term that's called
Bushido and all martial arts is based on
that term Bushido it means the way of
the warrior or the warrior spirit it's
telling you right off the bat it's
telling you this is what we're training
to become to become
Warriors only it's not Warriors for God
for Jehovah it's Warriors of the flesh
Satan Delights in war for it excites the
worst passions of the soul and then
sweep weeps into eternity its victims
steeped in Vice and blood it is his
object to incite the Nations to war
against one another for he can thus
divert the minds of the people from the
work of preparation to stand in the day
of God
within Christian circles many times
Christians will ask questions um what's
wrong with learning how to defend
oneself um is there something wrong with
our military what about our military
what what's wrong with them knowing how
to defend our country what about law
enforcement we have many people that you
know contact our ministry and say you
know what about the police officers what
if they didn't learn how to fight you
know where would we be there's a
distinct difference though between
military training and defending the
helpless than what is taught in martial
arts we've only seen military in our
country since the 1950s being introduced
into martial Arts since the founding of
this country we've had uh Warriors we
had armies and these armies never were
trained in eastern mystical combative
techniques or spiritual techniques only
since the 1950s after World War II was
the martial arts brought back with our
soldiers many of them when they were
stationed uh in the war in okanawa they
picked up the idea of the martial arts
they saw men that you know traditionally
are smaller in stature smaller in build
they saw these little Oriental men able
to do seemingly impossible or superhuman
Feats of Strength and speed so when they
saw this and they brought it back with
them we started seeing an influx of
Asian Masters and first it was the
Japanese and the Okana aans um teaching
Judo and
jiujitsu and then it began to develop
farther in the 60s we started getting
more of the the Eastern mysticism with
yoga and the hip movement all along that
timeline while these these Arts these
mystical ideas and philosophies are
being brought into our country the media
is picking up and running rampant with
it we're seeing martial arts movies you
know I remember you know Bruce Lee Enter
the Dragon that was like the greatest
martial arts movie that anyone had ever
seen um we had the Green Hornet we had
David kerine with Kung Fu and as we
progressed in the through the 70s and
the 80s we had Chuck Norris movies so
these Heroes were being put before the
minds of our families and our childrens
even traditional fundamental
Christianity was now looking at what was
once considered esoteric and occult
power as is this physical is this a
physical thing that we've just not
learned how to tap into yet so with
those movies I mean I was intrigued I
mean because we could do these things in
real life we always went to the movies
to see you know how they were portraying
you know the Arts we were practic iing
there was one man in particular that
really set the stage for modern day
martial arts his name was gichin
fukushi this man um was one of the
founders and fathers of modern day
karate and I remember seeing his quote
in books uh on dojo walls and often
times when parents take their students
Little Johnny and Susie into sign up for
karate this quote is the one that wins
them punuk cushi said something he said
martial arts is not about winning or
losing it's not about competing and
defeating your enemy it's about the
Perfection of the character of its
participants and when you when you hear
that it makes you feel wow that's what I
want for my children I want to perfect
their character I want them to be
self-motivated self-disciplined
self-control I want them to have
self-esteem as I do for my children what
they don't realize and what most the
instructors won't show you is the cover
of his book his master's textbook book
on the martial arts and when you see the
cover of that book and the image that is
on there you begin to realize the
character that is actually being
developed in the martial arts the War
character a few years ago when I was
looking at that image I thought where
did this come from I mean you don't just
pick an image that looks blatantly
demonic an image of rage and power for
no reason and as I researched I found
that image it was an image of one of the
12 Asian zodiac Gods so it was this
image that was being portrayed through
the punching the kicking the fighting
continually training in The Art of War
martial arts means The Art of War
martial art so is this the character
that we want to develop in our children
and in our own lives I remember as I was
training when I was growing close to
making black belt a first Dawn in kung
fu or black asash as the Chinese would
say I was fighting with my greatest
competitor he was another Advanced brown
belt and that rank took the longest it
was over 2 and A2 years to go from
Advanced Brown to black belt and we
fought every single week this guy
outweighed Me by close to 120
lbs and through the training we had
learned how to push through no matter
what the obstacle
was when the day came and and I was
fighting this opponent this uh this
other Advanced brown belt I remember the
instructor stopping the fight it was in
the afternoon and looking at me and he
said that's good enough my instructor
pulled me to the side and he gave me a
date he said how does may sound and I
knew what he was talking about and he
just smiled and for the next few weeks
he didn't even bring it up when that day
came I drove up to the school you know
with my wife and children there was
going to be all these alumni of the
school old High ranks brown belts
Advanced brown belts and green belts
that had had been there from years
before coming to support and to be a
part of the
ceremony when we got out of the car my
instructor my sefue he had one of the
high ranks come and take my wife and
children and lead them into the school
and he took me separately to a separate
room outside of the school and he sat me
down and he told me he said Eric he said
I want to tell you something he said you
may not understand this now but you will
one day he said what's about to happen
to you what you are about to participate
in is more like a marriage than a
promotion and then he walked out of the
room and he left me there to
think as I came into the school you know
an hour or so later after the ceremony
was all set up there was a path of
candles and the instructor would walk in
and then the higher ranks the brown B
and advanced brown belts and then each
one of the green belts would walk in and
the brown belts carrying a candle
setting it down setting as it were a
path of fire that you walk through to
achieve this
moment when I came in after and walked
down that
path I came in in front and the the
school was full there were hundreds of
people there and I sat down in front
with my instructor you know in a Lotus
position with the cross legs and he sat
down there in front of me and I sat down
and he gave a speech you know he told
about you know the achievements and the
difficulties that I'd
overcome as he was doing this I looked
and there was the traditional Asian
teapot for the Tea Ceremony there was
also two Candles there and he told me he
said when we do this ceremony he said
you reach up and you put the candle out
with your finger and afterward we did
the Tea Ceremony the tea ceremony was
one teapot him pouring and me pouring
and then us both drinking from the same
water and that was very symbolic what it
meant was is that his teachings were now
my teachings his life was now my life
his Spirit was now my spirit it made us
and joined us as
one after the ceremony we had a dinner
and I remember at the dinner I mean
there was all these people all these
family members and students there and I
was so used to from my upbringing
helping other people so I started to go
over and help the high ranks the green
belts to serve people and I Remember The
Grandmaster came over to me and he
touched me on the shoulder and he pulled
me to the side and he said you're not
part of that group anymore you're not
supposed to be serving he said come up
here and sit so I went up to the table
and sat down with the other black belts
and The Grandmaster sat beside me and he
said you are to be served and all these
green belts began to bring the food to
us and at that point it was like the
Lord sent up a red flag something's not
right about this this is exactly
opposite from what God's word says in
Matthew chap 20 Jesus tells us you know
that the princes of the Gentiles and the
unbelievers exercise Authority and
dominion over them and they that are
great or powerful exercise Authority
upon on those that are weak but it shall
not be so among you for whosoever will
be great among you shall be your servant
and whosoever shall be Chief among you
let him be your
minister these thoughts were were racing
through my mind you know why am I now
being served when I should be the one
that is serving and at the same time
that Spirit of Pride that had been
growing for 14 years Within
Me liked the position of being served
liked the attention I was now beginning
to realize that martial arts is not just
about fighting and selfdefense but it's
budo it's a way of life the term budo
literally means the Marshal
way every style especially those in the
in the okan Styles the Japanese Styles
the d whether it be Jun do or karate do
or Judo or Aikido means the way after
that ceremony I went to the school the
following week and I was taking private
instruction at that time because I
really wanted to make sure that I
could that I could achieve and and
progress in the
Arts and my instructor came up to me and
he asked me a very a very pointed
question and I noticed that something
had changed between he and I from that
ceremony now instead of him looking down
at me it was it was as though a wall had
been taken down that kept the student
away from the master and he asked me a
question he said Eric he said what is it
that you want from the martial arts now
now that you've achieved black belt you
know where do you want to go and I told
him very plainly I said I want what you
have I want the abilities that you have
the things that I had seen him for those
14 years do that seemed magical my
instructor encouraged me to begin
training in other Arts um my primary
focus had been on on full contact and on
the animal Styles he began to encourage
me to train in other arts in iido in
Judo in the okan Styles in most martial
arts
Styles a black belt or a first degree or
a first Dawn is considered a beginning
disciple it's a follower of the way a
follower of the art again not just the
physical techniques but the way of life
so you begin to follow the master
whoever that instructor is whatever his
rank
is so as I did
this I wanted to be officially a
disciple I wanted the title of a
disciple and my instructor had told me
that to achieve that the training and
the focus of training had to begin to be
purely on Chi on the internal strength
so all of my focus all of my attention
began to be in any art that I was
training in how is this art related to
Chi how can I use this art to achieve
these supernatural abilities The Shaolin
Temple says in their own writings that
the relationship between a master and
his disciple is stronger than that of
blood so through this practice and W and
with me it was five six days a week I
went to church once a week on Sabbath
the rest of the time I was training
martial arts whenever I was out with my
friends it was about martial arts
everything became martial arts
focused as I was being drawn deeper into
the martial arts I was being pulled
slowly away from the bonds of my family
I can remember when it would be my
anniversary my wedding anniversary and I
would tell my wife let's do it the next
day because I've got something really
important in the Arts that have to be
done that night um so we would postpone
things with my wife and children in
order that I could put the martial arts
first I remember one
weekend my wife and I were sitting there
talking and she told me that she'd had a
dream and I've never really you know
given much credit to dreams I mean
they're just dreams my wife was very
concerned about this she said Eric she
said this was from the Lord she said I
saw the high ranks at your school and
she said they were all standing in a
circle with their arms linked one to
another and she said behind them on the
outside of the circle I saw the wives
and the mothers and the children and it
was as though the circle was growing
Tighter and the families were being
pushed to the
outside after my wife shared with me
this dream and I could tell that it
bothered her you know
tremendously I became angry and I didn't
realize it then but I do now there was a
division of loyalties I felt like she
was trying to pull me away from this
thing that that had meant so much to me
this art that had had filled my life and
I became angry I thought she doesn't
understand I began training even harder
determined not to allow anything to
stand between me and the dreams of my
youth but it was I who did not
understand for I had allowed my own self
desires to come between my wife and I if
only I had listened in faith and obeyed
the word of the Lord that lifegiving
word which is still speaking to each of
us
today my son give me thine heart and let
Thine Eyes observe my ways husbands love
your wives even as Christ also loved his
church and gave himself for
her this is the battle that faces every
man
to love his wife his children and to
love all others above himself in
frustration and Rebellion I turned away
from the one that was calling for my
heart not realizing that it is only
through this surrender that Victory and
freedom are finally
won the night which I longed for finally
came two of us were to be recognized and
awarded the title of disciples in kung
fu it was a private ceremony one which
only the high ranks were permitted to
attend and now after training and
teaching for 17 years in the martial
arts myself and the men whom I had first
seen awarded the coveted black belt were
now being honored with the rank
equivalent of a fifth Dawn I remember
the grandmas when he walked in to the
discipleship ceremony myself and that
gentleman that had made Advanced brown
belt that I had fought in the beginning
both of us made disciple the same night
we were the first ones in over 30 years
to make that rank it was the equivalent
of a fifth degree a fifth
Dawn when The Grandmaster walked in he
had this huge staff in his hand and
there was hair horse hair coming out of
it and there were carvings on the side
of it and after the ceremony when
everyone was gone you know we asked him
about that you know where did that come
from I'd been there for all these years
and never seen that even in display and
he told me he said that staff was used
only when someone made a disciple and I
know now that that was a shaman staff
even though this man loved the Lord you
know was a professed Christian he was
blending light and darkness
together after that point we had a
private lesson with him that week after
that
ceremony
and this The Grandmaster told us
something that I'll never forget he
looked at at me and the other gentleman
there and he told us he said said what
you all are learning to do
now you would be considered Wizards if
this was done 100 years ago for the last
2 and 1/2 years myself and the other
disciple had trained in ways I could
have never before imagined we spent
hours each day meditating standing in a
low horse stance upon balance beams and
shall in Plum fire poles striving to tap
into and harness this mystical power
called Chi
through meditation deep breathing and
visualization techniques we were taught
to change the temperature of our bodies
and through the power of our minds to
influence and control both our
environment as well as those with whom
we fought to advance in this training I
was required to compromise the very
clear instructions of the word of God
and with each further step I took on
this path of Disobedience my heart grew
harder and my ears more deaf to the
voice of my father's
love God's word being removed the
foundation of my life began to crumble
beneath me and our family and home was
being Swept Away in the storm the ties
which had bound me to My Savior and the
Covenant with my wife slowly had been
eroded
away during this time after I had made
my
discipleship my marriage and my family
began to become very
shaky and I was back battling with
something inside that I couldn't voice
to
others everything that I was going
through with this fight of staying
married of fighting for my wife fighting
for my children and then the martial
arts pulling me the other direction this
was harder than any battle that I had
ever faced before and nothing that the
martial arts had taught me gave any hope
of Freedom or victory in this fight
against
sin in the martial arts they told us
that everything was okay in moderation
there were no absolutes there was no
absolute black and white everything had
a relative
[Music]
gray the word of God tells us clearly
that no man can serve two masters and
for more than 16 years I had attempted
to do just that while attending church
each week with my family my heart had
been slow slly drawn away from the
things of the Lord and my home I had
allowed the martial arts and the desires
of my own carnal heart to come between
my wife and I and the Covenant which I
had made to her and to my God this was
perhaps the greatest battle I had ever
faced through the years of my training
in the Arts and full contact fighting I
thought I had prepared myself to face
any conflict but now I realized that
none of the Master's teachings nor the
training of the flesh had prepared me
for
this for we wrestle not against flesh
and blood but against principalities and
Powers against spiritual wickedness in
the heavens against the rulers of the
darkness of this world not only in the
church but in our homes and even within
our own lives does this battle
wage the enemy I was now facing was
within my own heart and mind and I knew
not how to free myself from my own
selfish desires and the flesh nor from
the voices I had listened to and obeyed
for so many years voices which speak to
each of us every day through television
and movies through music and the printed
page and the voices which had spoken to
me through the Grandmasters and teachers
of the Arts which I
practiced the Lord promises us that the
weapons of our Warfare are not weak and
carnal but they are Mighty and full of
power through God to the pulling down of
strongholds the stronghold of Lies which
the devil Whispers in our ears casting
down imaginations and every High thing
which exalts itself Against The Knowing
of God and bringing into captivity every
thought to the perfect Obedience of
Christ but how few Avail themselves of
that Victory which the Lord Jesus Christ
is waiting and ready to to freely give
to be a genuine Christian truly a
disciple and follower of the Lord means
more than just believing in Jesus it
means more than just attending church
once a week and reading a few verses in
the morning before you rush out into the
world the lord Jehovah Yahweh is not
asking for 70% of your life to be truly
Born Again cost everything it will cost
you your life the martial arts had
taught me to look inward to myself
rather than upward to Christ to follow
my feelings rather than the instructions
of God's holy word and now there was a
war taking place a war which began more
than 6,000 years ago in heaven and
although unseen to the common eye this
war rages with intensity within every
man woman and child for there are people
struggling in darkness battling with
internal foes all around us each and
every day there are souls that are
starving for the bread and the Water of
Life waiting longing for someone who
truly believes the words of Christ and
who knows his love and great power to
deliver and to save now when I needed
the Lord the most when I needed clear
discernment and to know and to hear his
voice I had become both blind and deaf
to his spirits and instruction although
I wanted a solution to the problems in
our marriage I could no longer read and
understand the scriptures as I once had
light had become Darkness to me and evil
now appeared as good for the Bible says
spiritual things can only be spiritually
discerned I had spent so many years
listening to reading and hearing the
voice of the serpent through the martial
arts my instructors and the media that I
could no longer discern the voice of my
Father in Heaven as he spoke through his
holy word for the carnal mind and the
flesh is enmity against God it is not
subject to the law of God neither indeed
can
be I Fought the Battle going on in my
mind for almost 6 months but I fought it
only as I had been taught in the Arts by
the power of my own will and flesh and
regardless of the training no man is a
match for Satan and his Legions of
Fallen Angels without Christ in
frustration I yielded to the voice of
the dragon and my own selfish desires
for freedom and I filed for a divorce I
cannot put into words how our family was
broken when yielding to the carnal
desires of One's Own Heart rather than
the word of God few realize the lives
their decisions will affect For Eternity
for the heart is deceitful above all
things and who can know it I remember so
clearly that last day when I drove the
moving truck to our country home to pick
up the remaining furniture that I was
taking with me and as I pulled out of
our gravel driveway I did not see my
wife and small son as they stood in the
doorway crying out to the Lord in heaven
for his mercy and help nor did I see the
six-year-old little girl running behind
my truck crying daddy daddy wait please
don't leave it wasn't until years later
that I realized what my leaving had done
to my wife and children's lives my wife
Sarah began to fight the fight of Faith
refusing to believe that the Lord would
not keep his word she daily claimed his
promises repeating out loud what the
Lord hath joined together let no man put
us under for with the heart we believe
under righteousness and with our mouth
confession is made unto salvation for
whosoever believeth on him shall not be
put to shame and while my wife lost
herself in the Lord in her Bible and
fasting in prayer I plunged even deeper
into the darkness of the Arts which had
been the dream of my youth struggling
struggling to silence the voice of the
Lord and my own guilty conscience I can
remember seeing Sarah as she walked up
the steps to my apartment to drop off
our children she looked so thin and
fragile and yet there was a joy in her
eyes which I could not understand she
had found that for which I struggled so
hard to apprehend but no matter how far
I ran and regardless of the
entertainment and distractions the devil
used to occupy my time when I lay down
alone at night the silence was
deafening oh that thou hadst hearkened
under my Commandments for then had thy
peace been as a river and thy righteous
as the waves of the sea for great peace
have they that love my law and nothing
shall cause them to stumble and fall as
I sought for deeper knowledge and power
from the martial arts I also began
training more heavily in the Chinese
internal styles of taii Kuan bang and
Kong I remember the weekend when an
accomplished martial artist and close
friend of mine invited me to attend a
training seminar which is grandm was
holding in a city but a few hours from
where we lived I was excited about the
prospect of meeting this man a man of
his Rank and reputation and even more so
because he was known for his ability in
both demonstrating and teaching the use
of internal strength or Chi this man was
recognized as a 10th Dawn in two systems
of kung fu and a master teacher in
Chinese Kong a system which has as its
sole purpose the Marshal and medical
development of chi power and
energy after the day's training was over
The Grandmaster came and spoke with a
small group of students from the area he
gave instructions to the black belts and
their pupils in regard to their training
which they quickly left to
complete once alone The Grandmaster
addressed me personally and although we
had never met before he told me that it
was not by chance that I was there that
day for according to an old Chinese
proverb when the student is ready it is
then that the master will appear from
that day forward I looked for every
opportunity to train under this man for
not only did he have the knowledge to
teach me but he also had the authority
to ensure my progress in the ranks above
fifth dawn of all that I learned during
those years one thing stands out in my
memory to this very day late one night
after a hard day of training he began to
speak of the riddle of internal energy
and Chi and how this power was achieved
but to my surprise instead of telling of
ancient Chinese warriors and sages he
spoke of the artistic ability of many of
today's modern musicians men such as
Clapton hendris and others he compared
the energy which we were taught to use
in kung fu to that which these Legends
of Rock and Roll Channel while playing
the most sensual and ungodly
music it was then that I was told that
to the beginner Chi is known simply as
internal strength while at the
intermediate levels Chi is taught to be
breath and at the final level Chi is
revealed to be
spirit and it is this spiritual energy
which is Manifest in a thousand
different forms to the martial artist it
is used for Speed and power to the
holistic healer it is used used to
channel vibrational energies to heal for
the corporate executive and leader it is
used to influence and manipulate those
beneath him to the actor it is used to
Mesmerize their audiences while for the
musician this spiritual energy is used
to inspire and to Quicken their
performance and control the minds and
emotions of their
listeners after a few years under his
instruction I was soon impressed that if
I was truly going to learn what this man
had to teach I could no longer serve two
masters after all it was common for
disciples to step out from under the
covering of their original teacher in
school and begin teaching on their own
and this I did now feeling freedom to
learn unhindered by divided loyalties I
began seeking to understand the hidden
thread which is woven throughout all the
Eastern Arts a power whose results could
be seen but whose Source remained ever
Elusive and concealed fi beneath a veil
I often made the long 6-hour drive to
the city where my new teacher lived and
taught and it was on one such visit that
I went to the grandmaster's home it was
here that I learned the secret for which
I and disciples around the world had
fought and trained for so many years as
I entered his home I saw that which was
most unexpected instead of images of
Shaolin Warlords long dead and monks in
their traditional robes and sashes I saw
hanging upon the walls of every room
tall life-sized tapestries of the Hindu
gods and
deities alarms were sounding in my mind
Echoes of the scripture warnings I had
been taught as a child Echoes which I
sought to ignore The Grandmaster asked
me that day a very puzzling question he
said if all martial arts begin at
Shaolin which I knew they did
then why do we see such different
expressions of that one and same art I
was stunned and yet intrigued for this
was that very question for which I had
sought an answer all of these years yet
had never been able to put into words
how did he know to ask me that question
the alarm rang louder in my
mind the year was
2007 I had achieved everything that I'd
ever dreamed of in the martial arts
one night I was teaching a class in a
Chinese style called bang it's very much
like taii all the movements are very
slow very precise there's a lot of deep
breathing um internal meditation
focusing within as you do the movements
of the
form as I was doing this form I was
leading my students Through the Motions
in a circle and as we circled we would
focus on breathing in certain hand
gestures called
mudras then as we completed the circle
we would reverse and go the opposite
way as I was doing this I looked into
the eyes of my
students I was looking to see if they
were really tapping into that power that
the martial arts is supposed to reveal
is supposed to impart to
you as I looked in their eyes I noticed
that almost every one of them was in the
trance and they were drenched in
sweat now because of the martial arts
training I knew that this is not
possible humanly or physically speaking
we had not done anything to to bring the
body to a sweat we had not done anything
physical there was no
calisthenics at that
moment my mind was taken above what we
were doing
and as I was teaching this form it was
as though I was looking down from above
and I was seen a design or a pattern
that we were forming on the floor of the
dojo this had never happened to me
before it was very much like a like a
farmer with crop circles when he walks
out into his field he just sees a mess
but if he sees it from above from an
aerial view you can see a distinct
pattern
the pattern that I saw was a
circle with a DOT right in the center
much like a bull's eye the thing that I
struggled with was that I had seen this
same symbol in all of the martial arts
literature the writings the books of the
Masters and
Grandmasters I went home that night and
I went through my library searching
through iido books the Japanese styles
through the Kung Fu and Kong books the
Chinese internal Styles in every style
that I looked I found that same
symbol and I also found the meaning of
that symbol the symbol meant the sun god
or the
[Music]
da I was not sure how to tell my
students I mean how do you tell close to
100 people that an art that we had been
teaching at the school was actually
invoking the spirit of of the sun
god so the next week at my advanced
class the high rank class I told my
students I had a homework project for
them I wanted them to go home and do
research on this symbol so I drew the
symbol on our chalkboard and I gave them
their assignment the following week when
I came
in it was like dead silence you could
have heard a pin
drop each one of those students was very
sof
I asked them to get up and present
before the class what they had found and
when I'd given them this assignment I
told them that it didn't matter where
they found their information I just
wanted to see what they could find on
that symbol they looked in history books
they looked in Aztec and Mayan writings
they looked in Egyptian um hieroglyphics
they looked in Greek Roman they looked
in Babylonian
they also looked in Tattoo books they
looked in books on wiah and
Witchcraft and each one of them one
after another got up and presented the
information they had found and all of
them regardless of the source found the
same thing the symbol of the sun god or
the da or Yin and yangong as it is known
in the
Chinese after doing this after realizing
what the symbol really stood for
one of my students asked what does this
mean what are we going to do how does
this change what we're doing and I told
them from that point on we would no
longer be teaching that class we would
no longer be teaching the art of
bwa but as I went home that night I knew
that there was more than what I had just
seen so I began searching through all of
the studies that I had that I had done
all of my books in literature on the
internal martial arts of taiichi and
yoga keong and even the Shaolin arts and
as I searched I began to realize that
there was more working Within These Arts
than I had wanted to believe memories of
my mother's apprehension and discernment
when I took that first step on that
night so long ago now it was becoming
clear that the spiritual forces which
enabled the abilities in the Arts I had
practiced had also rought in my family's
destruction but now the Lord was calling
me my son it is time to come home he was
fighting to set me free from the chains
in which I was bound and revealing to my
wife and children the power of his
unfailing word and as the Lord was
reuniting our marriage and family he was
also restoring sight to my blinded eyes
within a week I made the announcement to
my student body that we were no longer
going to be offering or teaching the
internal art such as Tai Chi Kong bwa
and and even Shaolin Kung
Fu now I was trying to separate and
divide the martial arts physical from
the martial arts
spiritual this was very difficult I
attempted it for probably six or S
months at the end of s
months I realize that you cannot
separate the spiritual roots of martial
arts from their physical
practice when I made this announcement
to my
students I lost probably 40% of my
student body this um it hurt financially
but it also hurt to know that I had lost
students some of which had been with me
for many
years one night I came home from
teaching class it was late probably
11:30 almost
12:00 I walked in the
door and as I walked through the kitchen
I remember remember setting down my gym
bag my workout bag you know beside the
doorway I stepped over to the
refrigerator to get something to
drink as my hand reached out to open the
refrigerator
door the hair on the back of my neck
stood on end I felt an enormous presence
behind
me something that terrified
me after all these years in martial arts
and full contact fighting I thought I
wasn't afraid of
anything what this was behind me
terrified
me I didn't know what to do it was like
in that moment all these thoughts all
the teachings of the Masters I had read
and studied under went racing through my
mind do I fight do I
run but neither one would have done any
good both were
feudal and I was scared to turn around I
did not even want to see what this was
that was towering behind me it felt like
it was 10 or 12T tall it was
enormous at that moment I heard a
name sounding in my
ears the name of Jesus
Christ and as I heard that name there
was a spark a spark of hope and I
thought thought is it possible that he
would save me even after everything that
I've done even after the the pain and
the hurt that I've caused my family and
others will he save and Deliver
Me in Acts chapter 2 we have been given
the promise that whosoever calls upon
the name of the Lord Adonai The
Sovereign King shall be
delivered I thought can it really be
that simple
is it possible will he really hear and
come to my
rescue in that moment I fell on my knees
I looked up and I cried out with all
that I had Within Me Jesus Save Me Jesus
Yeshua save
me I don't know how long I cried tears
were were rolling down my face I could
still feel that presence behind me and I
just kept calling on the name of Jesus
Christ after what seemed like an
eternity I felt something else enter the
room it was as though a hand grabbed
this thing that was behind me this
spirit this demon that was standing
behind me and flung it out of the
room I didn't see anything but it was as
though you could feel it I was you know
covered in tears and I was crying out to
the
Lord at that
moment I came to know the Lord as my
personal
savior at that moment the Lord had shown
himself that he was mighty to save
[Music]
it's yoga has in the last few years
really exploded for Americans a lot of
folks swear by it some Christians though
believe there's actually a real problem
with
[Music]
yoga meditate on this I will I put the
force into the movies in order to try to
awaken a certain kind of
spirituality the spirit that I received
from the Masters and I trained under
some of the best in the world uh that
Spirit was one of violence it was
different it's limiting to just label it
martial arts it's just a way of life
should really definitely grow
emotionally definitely even spiritually
[Music]
he yeah
oh
[Music]